nba analyst from espn mr
tim lagler 10-year nba veteran as well
welcome tim what's happening good to be
on guys
how you doing buddy good man so uh any
any big trades uh that did happen
that may have taken you back a little
bit or surprised you or
also some trades that ultimately didn't
happen that surprised you maybe
especially with the la lakers who seem
to be in a free fall right
now you know i would say these days i'm
so used to being to being you know what
comes my way at the trading deadline i'm
not shocked by what actually goes down
in most of the trades that went down
were rumored to happen so i was kind of
anticipating it
um i think something that didn't happen
was
philadelphia not getting kyle lowry i
really thought they were going to go all
in
on making that happen i think ultimately
what may have changed their minds
seeing how this works playing as well as
they have while embiid's been out
has actually changed their mind on what
they're willing to give up
to swing for the fences with kyle lowry
uh and that's really interesting to me
because i still think they they were
going to need him
to have a legitimate fighting chance
against a team like brooklyn because
ultimately brooklyn has as much
offensive talent at the top of the
roster as any team in the history of
this league when you talk about raw
scoring power there's never been a team
that's had three guys on the same team
that brooklyn has
so for philly i thought adding lowry a
guy that's had big playoff moments he's
won a championship
uh he's a leader he could also help take
the ball out of ben simmons hands more
which i think is important for that team
particularly in big moments because
uh simmons you know inability to score
outside the paint i just think it blogs
their offense down at times
so that to me was a little bit
surprising it didn't happen they got
george hill instead i like george hill a
lot he's gonna help them he's a nice
veteran guard to pick up a lot of
playoff experience he can he can
certainly make threes playing off
simmons in a beat
but he's not going to have that dramatic
impact and give you a 25 point game in a
playoff game if that's what it takes on
a given night
kyle lowry could have done that so a
little bit surprised that they weren't
able to make that happen
uh lakers standing pat i'm not shocked
by it but i do think it's a little
unnerving
uh if you're a laker fan because they
just kind of sat there watch
and watch the nuggets get better they
watch the clippers get better your utah
is already a team that's kinda on the
radar that they didn't expect to be
looking at
uh looking up at in the western
conference so that they just kinda sat
there expecting hey we're gonna get
these two guys back when we do
we added two guys in the off season in
shooter harold we're right back where we
need to be
and defend our title but i think that
denver and clippers has got a lot closer
to him
uh most impactful trade which one do you
think has set up a team
for the best possible uh finish to this
nba season
i think it's a tie between aaron gordon
and rajon rhonda so aaron gordon goes to
the nuggets and you know you looked at
denver a year ago they beat the clippers
you know
go to the conference finals they've got
a guy in yoka choosing the mvp
discussion they've got
in a big that dominates the game
controls the game like no other big
right now in the league
you got an all-star garden jamal murray
who showed you last year what he's
capable doing in the post he's under
pressure
michael porter junior is that next guy
he's you know had some injuries to deal
with he was out beginning this year
he's every night getting better he's
very close to just stamping his arrival
in this league as a star
so what do you do you got yet aaron
gordon i mean you talk about adding the
perfect fit of
a fourth option now offensively because
he's certainly no slouch offensively he
can give you
you know sixteen eighteen twenty point
games when you need it if one of those
other guys is not playing well
but more importantly for me it's his
defensive prowess and his size to be
able to guard
lebron and a and kawhi leonard and paul
george i mean you just added
a legitimate all league caliber
defensive player
to your rip to your mix that you don't
have to run any place for
so your offense isn't disrupted that's a
big addition and then
rondo the clippers you know look at the
clippers and say well what are they have
they lacked
even last year when they've been
acquired paul george their first year
together but even in
years before that when they had chris
paul and blake and all those guys and
they just kept coming up small in the
playoffs
couple things one vocal leadership
rhonda brings vocal leadership to this
team and we have two guys as quiet as
paul george cry leonard you need
the emotion on the court and that little
bit of spark plug he brings that
he brings an iq that's off the charts
one of the smartest players ever play in
this league
and then for me most importantly look at
his
playoff resume and go back and find
specific moments in time
that he has absolutely come up in a huge
way on both ends of the floor
to get his team through an important
moment or a series and he did it again
last year i don't know the lakers win a
championship last year without rajon
rondo
so you add that to the mix the clippers
got substantially better so i look at
those two teams now and uh in a
different way than i did you know 24
hours ago
definitely and and now you're talking
about a west where for a couple days now
i've been talking about
you know as they increasingly
increasingly lose
basketball games and fall down the
the the rankings of where they are
they are more likely if lebron and 80 do
not come back and they don't
make something move here with andre
drummond or maybe lamarcus aldridge
somebody uh to to to solidify that
that uh frontcourt for that back or that
frontcourt form
you know this is a team that could be
looking at a playing game to get into
the playoffs when the guys get back and
get healthy if they do
yeah no it's a good point i don't know
that they'll fall that far uh
i think they'll be back soon enough to
keep it from getting to that point but
here's the there's a big difference okay
if you're
if you end up in the even i say the four
five you are now gonna have to play
you know you gotta play your tail off to
get out of the first round and then
immediately get the one seat
so there's no easy path you know if you
end up where they should have
which is like one or two you know not
the seven or eight is going to be a
pushover there's some good teams down
there too i mean you could get a dallas
team with luka dodges on a potentially
um so you got good teams down there too
but you're not going to sweat that out
the way that you are now with this path
and there's no doubt
these teams are coming for them and i
think they stood
pat because they believe their big
acquisitions
took place in the summer they added
dennis shooter they added mantras harold
to go to a championship team that's
already got two of the
top five players in the nba on it in
anthony davis lebron james so
that's the way they viewed and that's
that happened some years you know
everybody gets busy to train deadlines
some teams say wait a second we already
made our moves
in the summer um and so it feels a
little bit more
like you know earth shattering to lakers
fancy yeah we didn't do anything well
yeah they did a lot actually in the
offseason
but the question is going to be do they
get back enough time and does anthony
davis stay
healthy once he does come back it to be
able to make this run again through a
much
tougher top of the west and it's not in
the bubble anymore this is going to be
now
different you're going to have to travel
whether it's crowds in the building or
not it's just a different environment
than what they faced
a year ago in the bubble when the
conditions were perfect for veteran
players like lebron and a.d
to take that wear and tear off their
bodies to be able to have that run
that that's now added back into the mix
uh with some you know possibly serious
travel here in the postseason so
it's just a different element now for
the lakers than it was i thought it was
a foregone conclusion they were gonna
win the championship before the season i
said why even play let's just play 10
games and play the playoffs because
i didn't see any team being able to do
it but brooklyn obviously changed all
that by adding james harden
so that that immediately changed that
conversation and now with what denver
has done with what the clippers have
done
with how good utah's looked all year you
know phoenix is interesting but i think
they're too young maybe to make that
jump and then even the top of the east
philly better than they have been no
question milwaukee definitely the best
option they've had since giannis got
there
with the three guys they added uh miami
ads victor oladipo to a team that went
to the finals
you know across the board all of these
teams making moves to get better
so the lakers just found themselves in a
much more crowded neighborhood
we're speaking with tim legler from espn
nba analyst
10-year nba veteran um
you know after you talked to us today
about about the brooklyn nets
are they the the team right now that
everybody's looking up at
and who they're gonna have to figure out
to beat in the playoffs
it has to be it just has to be there's
there's just never been a collection
that we've ever seen with this kind of
raw scoring power it's it's really kind
of incredible you think about the three
guys that are paired together and
they're gonna make it work because
you know that's the with the big
question what what kyrie irving gonna do
he could implode at any time look at
he's still a little bit iffy you know
with somebody some of the moves he makes
um including you know three game you
know departure for the team for for
personal reasons right now
that also coincided with his birthday
i'm not making any assumptions i'm just
saying that is that these are the kind
of things people talk about what went on
at the beginning of the year
you know when he missed time so you know
can you 100 percent count on him i don't
know that you can but i think the one
thing he's proven when he is there
and he's locked in he's fully accepting
of this role playing off of james harden
just like he did
playing off of lebron james when he was
at his best as an nba player
they figured that part out it's james
harden's team once they got that settled
kevin durant doesn't care who he plays
with you could put kevin durant with the
you know you can find the three most
selfish players in the history of the
league
kevin ran still going to get 30 he's
going to do it efficiently because he's
just that good
so i'm not worried about him and now
that they have figured that out
you look at this team and you go how are
you supposed to come up
with enough of a defensive game plan
to stop all of the ways that those guys
can beat you including with their
passing
and who has the personnel to do it
nobody so
you look at that team and say look if
those guys come back and they stay back
it's it's it's hard to imagine somebody
being able to beat that team four times
before they beat you
yeah that's i mean when the playoffs
come that's always the biggest question
i ask when you got teams like that you
know you play seven games you get you
tell me
you're going to beat them four times
that's that's incredibly difficult uh
let's get you out of here on this
uh tim legler from espn nba analyst
talking to us about the uh the nba
season
and the trade deadline that ended the
buyout market
a couple names that keep being talked
about lamarcus
aldridge down in san antonio who's 35
and
the younger version andre drummond in
cleveland do you see a good fit for
either one of those players and if so
where
where would that look like yeah i like
to i like what i'm hearing about
aldridge to miami i think for me that
but probably even move the needle a
little bit more than
victrola oladipo because victor depot i
think he's got more in the tank in terms
of you know being
close to what he was at his peak but i
also think man they got a lot of guys to
do the same thing
so how's that gonna work me victor
oladipo was doing whatever we wanted to
down in houston same thing
in indiana now he's going to a team that
they they move it differently they share
it differently
they've got you know four other guys
that are playmakers
so i gotta see that see what that looks
like but aldridge is a different element
he's a guy that if you want to slow the
game down and throw it into the post and
run your offense to him
uh for several minutes he's still a
really difficult match up in the low
post
and he's a very good pick and pop player
and they've got a ton of guys that run
off ball screens with the ball
to be able to knock down 18 foot jump
shot playing off of those guys
i think he's a really nice fit for them
uh and then you know andre drummond
you know the big guy is just not valued
to that extent the way
that he plays i mean he's a legit big
beating you up in the paint on the glass
you need that but i don't know that i
look at him and say wow that's that's
game changer if he goes here it goes
here maybe a team like boston
if they can pick them up for cheap i
know the knicks are rumored that
might be an interesting one because who
would have thought the knicks would be
sitting where they are
um in the four or five spot in the
eastern conference at this point so they
might be closer than they thought you go
out you had a big there's a lot of
rumors about that
he's definitely going to help somebody
but i also think the way the game is
played now there's just not a premium
on those guys one last point i want to
make one thing that did happen yesterday
the trading deadline
it may have saved the nba this year
because
this regular season has been brutal
nobody plays
i mean any game you watch on any given
night put on a marquee match up
nobody's out there i've never seen so
many star players
not playing in the marquee games that
everybody looks forward to it's been
brutal
and so now what happens you got a
different adrenaline about what these
put this postseason is going to look
like so i think if nothing else
yesterday it saved the league because
now everybody's looking forward to may
18th in the postseason starting i think
at a higher level than they were
because this has been a very difficult
regular season to watch because of all
the guys missing time
hey i i'm there with you man i'm you
know i i'm not a big mba guy during the
regular season i usually tune in and
really kind of lock it in when the
playoffs come so
you know regular season basketball in
the nba you know has kind of become one
of those things where
you know you you ultimately know where
it's going to go you know at some point
so
uh i get it i i hope the this trade
deadline really moves some things around
like you said uh everybody tim legler
from espn nba atlantis tim
thanks for joining us bud sure
appreciate appreciate it talk to you
guys soon
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here